bts brought the fire
and lit up the 2020 mtv video music
award
ladies and gentlemen i got some medicine
so you should keep your eyes on the ball
the super group performed their new hit
dynamite their first song fully recorded
in english
[Music]
it was a huge enormous shelling for all
of us
but you know we but we decided to do it
because you know
let's try something new let's challenge
something in this current situation
you know pandemic so every i think
everyone did well
quite well when we first listened to the
demo we just loved it and you know
let's keep it this way and we've done
we've done it this was bts's very first
performance
at the vmas the singers opened up to e.t
about preparing for the performance
you're performing diana dynamite for the
first time uh what can fans expect from
that performance
[Music]
and the vma goes to
[Applause]
bts on bts also took home four moon
person trophies
they kicked off the night winning best
group and their song
on earned them best kpop best pop and
best choreography
the boys used their acceptance speech to
thank their beloved army
wow thank you so much for her best pop
at the mtv
video music over here we are truly
honored and we want to give a credit to
our friends army
and people who support us and relate to
our music
yes it means so much to us
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]